Okay they're about to lock me in here
and then use these electric coils to
make magnetic fields that rotate. They're
roughly the strength of Earth's magnetic
field and we'll see if my brain is
picking up on the fact that the magnetic
field is changing. The whole time I'll
have my eyes closed
it'll be pitch black in here, basically
no stimuli except for the changing
magnetic field and I'll keep my head
perfectly still facing forward.
that sound good?
-yeah gonna take about eight
minutes
eight minutes perfect okay
I'm ready when you are
but before we do this
let's meet the researchers. Can you
introduce yourself?
-introduce myself? ah
my name is Shin Shimojo. I'm a professor
in neuroscience and experimental
psychology at here Caltech Biology
Connie you are the first
author here and your paper has just been
published, when this video goes out.
So what is the setup of the paper how do you set this up?
So basically we wanted
to see if humans have any brain response
to a magnetic field.
it has long been recognized that certain
bird species have a remarkable ability
to find their way home, hence the use of
homing pigeons to carry messages for us.
their impeccable sense of direction is
owed in part to their ability to sense
the Earth's magnetic field
but they are not the only animals that do this
certain bacteria, bees, salmon, turtles
rats, dogs, whales, cats in all of them are
known to have magnetic compass.
Dogs, known to poop with their bodies oriented
preferentially north-south have even
been trained to locate bar magnets
Given a choice between three containers they
were much better than chance at
identifying the one containing the
magnet. In fact, they were much better at
finding a magnet than finding a food
treat under similar conditions
Given all
these examples it seems more likely that
humans should have the ability to detect
magnetic fields.
And if you're wondering
how humans could physically pick up the
magnetic fields, consider that magnetite
crystals have been found in the brain
that closely resembled those of
magnetically active bacteria
Myy colleagues
in neuroscience said 'wow this is hard to
believe you know this is impossible'
but lots of biologists and geophysicists
said well it's a matter of course humans
are not, you know, exceptions among all those
mammalian species.
But up till now the
evidence has been contradictory and controversial.
So in the early 80s
Robin Baker did some studies where they
took groups of students and drove them
around in very convoluted routes around
the English countryside.
And they were
blindfolded and then they would stop the
bus and ask the students to identify
which direction they came from.
So basically 'home' and they got a pretty
significant results from that.
Shortly afterwards maybe a few years afterwards
this study was attempted again at
Princeton University and they did just a
very similar experiment there and they
couldn't get significant behavioral results
there.
that's a controversy, lots of
positive reports and the failure of the
duplication, negative data in neuroscience
as well so let's step back and then see
if there's any systematic, selective
response from the brain to the magnetic
field itself not anything associated
like vestibular thing or visual scene, swinging and stuff like that.
So this is the test chamber, I'll turn on the light
so this is um our magnetic...
is that the way we get in
yes
that's the way you have to crouch in
So I'm gonna I'm gonna crawl under there.
-Yes and you sit down there...
hang on a sec hang on this
is too cool I really like it.
What.. whose
chair is that?
It just happened to be...
Joe's chair
Joe's reclining the chair
and not used for this purpose but it
turned out it's very relaxing
and the main reason of this cage is to shield the
outside effect for one thing and also
have a good control over the modified
Faraday cage where electricity is running
okay, so
and then there's no sound or vision
or tactile or any other additional
stimulation because we are tapping into
very subtle response of the brain at the
subliminal subconscious level.
It doesn't
block the Earth's magnetic field. The Earth's
magnetic field goes straight through
this and that's actually sort of what we
want because inside the chamber we're
not trying to override the Earth's field
we're just trying to redirect it just to
add a little bit of field here and here
remove a little bit there and by doing
that we can smoothly move the field back
and forth and move it in a way that
relates to how someone might experience
the field as they're sort of moving you
know around outside
so that's essentially what you're simulating in
here
yes
-is you're making it as though
my head is swiveling around in the
Earth's magnetic field
yes except that
if you actually doing it in the real
world then your vestibular system is
also sending signals. We are not
interested in contamination
from vestibular signals so we would like to
generate artificially that kind of
situation like this, however eliminating
any other sensory modalities such as vestibular.
Can I hop in there and just
have a look?
oh yeah, go ahead
of course - okay
I mean I feel like for
my job I have been in more weird
soundproof boxes than most people
These black coils here, do these create
the magnetic field?
No, so those are for a different experiment
so the magnet coils are actually these
things.
Those are the magnetic coils
And you can see there's four of these square
coils -yeah- in all three directions and
this is a nested three axis coil set and
it's designed to create a magnetic field
in any direction inside the chamber
and in the center of the chamber where
your head and torso is going to be.
mm-hmm
it's designed to create a uniform
field so a field with no gradients or
curves in it.
I've brought a compass and
so I can just see if the magnetic field
is changing, what's gonna happen when I
sit in this room.
okay that was a pretty
dramatic shift.
So there will be two
kinds of rotations one is clockwise and
one is counterclockwise and as a control
on some trials the magnetic field won't
change at all. So we can compare on
trials what happens after the field
rotation versus trials where no field rotated.
so this is the sort of thing
that I'll be experiencing but in the dark?
Yep.
Now we're gonna want you to use
your left hand to hold it here 'cause it's
easier than the front the cap yep.
On this cap there are 64 electrodes
which will pick up the electrical
activity of my brain
and you're sure this isn't just to make people look
stupid? - Oh, no, no, no
When you're awake with your eyes
closed the dominant signal is called the
alpha wave.
In most people it occurs
around 10 Hertz.
These little squiggles
right here they're happening at around 10
times per second, these are the alpha waves
We are measuring your alpha wave which is known to be an
indicator of relaxing and sometimes even
drowsy but not sleeping
and then when you notice something like in vision or
audition or touch your alpha wave is
suppressed and that is the signature of
a brain detecting sensory signal and
moving attention towards it.
So the goal of
this experiment is to determine if a
magnetic field rotation causes the
amplitude of alpha waves to drop.
I'm about to go into the cage
I'm gonna turn off the light. And then we
just do this with a stool
turn off all
the lights in the room and we close the
doors.
and throughout the experiment I'll be
listening in and watching the video
for safety reasons
Can you hear me?
Yes I can.
I'm setting up
the experiment. Um, we'll be starting shortly.
Just wait for the 'ding dings'
The experiment is starting, you can see that's
our starting point. In terms of
direction, it will
vary from
two preset values
yeah, so you can see there, that was a field rotation
This is like one of the more
glamorous
ahhhh...there we go.
That's what I was not meant to hit. Thank you.
Sorry about that.
I could see that happening.
You could see that coming. Man, I was thinking about saying
something to the camera.
I can't wait to see
the results though.
this is a section of
my raw EEG results. You can see that
every three seconds the field was
rotated either clockwise counter
clockwise or it was fixed, meaning it
didn't change. Now it's impossible to
draw conclusions just by looking at this
so the scientists average over all the
trials in the different conditions and
plot the alpha power over all the
electrodes.
This is a recording from
someone who is particularly sensitive to
changes in the magnetic field. As I play
this, watch how the clockwise and
counterclockwise responses compare to
the fixed field result.
the recording
starts before a rotation.
The magnetic stimulus takes place,
and now observe the
post stimulus response, particularly for counterclockwise
for this subject the
counter clockwise rotation resulted in a
clear decrease in alpha power of at
least three decibels shown by the dark
blue color. This corresponds to a
decrease in alpha power by around 50%
Now, here are my results. After the
magnetic stimulus my response to
counterclockwise is clearly not as
pronounced.
But over time for clockwise rotations my alpha power is reduced.
I was told I was neither the most
sensitive to magnetic fields nor the
least sensitive, I was somewhere in the
middle.
So the conclusion is that our
brains have ability to sense magnetic field
change but it's implicit and subliminal
it's non-conscious part of the brain.
This is just the first step to make sure
that it's not theoretically impossible
that our ancestors might have utilized
this ability for their navigation. Even the
modem people like ourselves may
potentially have it. This will open up
the window for the next
stage research as to how we could bring
it to the consciousness, how could we
strengthen them, and how could we utilize
it.
As yet it's unclear if anyone can
actually make use of this sense
consciously or subconsciously to help
them navigate, but the study's authors
point out that a surprising number of
human languages lack terms like front
back left and right and instead use
cardinal directions, North, South, East and
West.
Native speakers of such languages
would refer to a nearby tree as being to
their north rather than being in front
of them. Individuals who've been raised
from an early age within a linguistic
social and spatial framework using
cardinal reference cues might have made
associative links with geomagnetic
sensory cues to aid in daily life.
In other words, people from such cultures
may be conscious of their magnetoreception.
They would be very
interesting to test.
But if it turns out
that this sense is no longer functional
in humans, just a relic from our
ancestors, it would be interesting to
consider why we lost it.
Maybe modern world humans don't need it - that's
one explanation. Another explanation is
we are surrounded so much and exposed so
much to artificially created strong
magnetic fields, starting from the
airplane cabinet, headphones, some younger
people are wearing this for 10 hours per day.
including MRI scanner too.
So it's possible our internal compass may be a
victim of our modern technology.
This study does not show that magnetic fields
have some kind of special influence on
you, that they don't cure disease, they
don't make you smarter.
you can't communicate telepathically or something
through them
So these are the types of
emails that Connie does not want to
receive just so, just so everyone's
clear in case you've got sort of a crazy
idea.
my hair still looks stupid, In case
you have a crazy idea for what to do
with magnetic fields and the human brain
this this study does not support that.
no
it does not support that.
It only supports that the human brain
and pick up on the physical stimulus of
the Earth's magnetic field
yup
Which, in itself is a super cool finding.
it is a super cool finding, it's like the
basis for for future research because
you know you can't have any behavior
without some kind of something going on
in your brain.